and Brian the celebration continues all
over the valley tonight including at
Fremont Street Experience where the
canopy is displaying a video
highlighting the night's winning season
8 news now reporter Joshua peguero Joins
us live from there
Ryan Denise has been a steady stream of
people here and go their nights here
just partying on the Fremont seat of
spirits the crowd has died down but it's
like a spirits up and down but we were
all over downtown today we're at the
sources sports book earlier they went to
the circus Stadium swim and then
everyone was ecstatic when the night
school there first goal that was only
the beginning of the scored a total of
nine goals we spoke to locals who said
the Golden Knights win means so much for
this city
one to cry over sports but there was
tears in there
in my city needs this we love hockey
here it means the world to me I'm born
and raised here it's it's the first time
we won the Stanley Cup and it's it's
unbelievable like it feels like a dream
six six years
[Music]
now she's not going to famous words from
Golden Knights owner Bill Foley who said
he wanted to win the Stanley Cup in six
years those words seem so pressured
right now it's like he manifested this
win it's a story win and again the
canopy will be having golden knights
celebration thing uh three minute long
video to about midnight and eight and
um our 8 news now investigators found
out from sources there might be a parade
on Friday reporting live from the free
monster experience where people are
still out here partying Joshua faguero
eight news now back to you in the studio